A couple of weeks ago, you mentioned it could be good for me to take a binder when one
It is good to take a binder when one does a castoral pattern
Okay, so um
So
I mean, it's good for anybody to take a binder. Oh your binder is helping with phase
Five of the detoxification pathways. So
Phase five detox is making sure that you don't reabsorb stuff that you're pushing that your liver is working
So gosh darn hard to get into the smell of the tested and if you reabsorb it your liver is just gonna go
Oh my gosh, I quit. I'm taking a vacation. I'm not doing this anymore
So a binder will help grab on to it and hold it into the intestine to be deposits of the twin
Is it best to take the binder before or starting the castoral pack or take an after? Well
um
The binder is best to be taken on a more empty stomach
It's good you know to take one in the morning between meals and maybe one in the afternoon between meals or you could take it right before you go to bed
That's when I would take it